la visite parisienne de volody
mirzelinski sur les chaînes info je vous
ai présenté par Monsieur Meuble et oui
comment gagner du temps quand on est à
l'antenne mais que le navion tarde à se
poser plusieurs écoles il y a à l'école
Chronopost on invente une fourchette
horaire qui ne veut strictement rien
dire
viens d'arriver pour accueillir
maintenant dans quelques longues
secondes quelques toutes petites minutes
il y a une excellente interview ce matin
du président Zelinski dans le Figaro il
y a une phrase elle fait deux pleines
pages et il y a une seule phrase en
retenir vraiment qui marquante c'est
celle qu'enzelinski explique je crois
que Macron a changé et cette fois pour
de vrai mais normalement tous les élèves
devaient être dans la même salle mais
CE2 n'était pas là donc je vais voir
dans la seconde salle donc je fais le
tour déjà je trouve les CE2 mais ils
étaient où les CO2 sous la table sous
les tables ah ils étaient planqués
c'était planqué ouais mais qu'est-ce que
vous faites ça donc il y en a une de mes
élèves qui me dit on fait grève
pourquoi et comment ça vous nous donnez
trop de travail
[Applaudissements]
attendez c'est pas fini et le pire c'est
qu'après elle me dit toute façon on a
écrit au jugement
parce qu'il y avait trop de devoirs
de rire de partout et c'est vraiment un
grand souvenir ce que cette année là
j'avais la punition donc et double dose
on peut voir et continuer à leur donner
autant de travail il a donné un coup de
pied dans un ballon c'est un très grand
crime qui doit être immédiatement puni
il a donné un coup de pied dans un
ballon à l'effigieuse
de la République et avec son chien en
augmentant précisément l'idée du soft
dans son tweet il sait exactement ce
qu'il fait Thomas porte là oui c'est pas
un hasard mais oui bon ça y est on vous
entendu vous avez fait le boulot c'est
bon maintenant on peut être sérieux j'ai
fait le boulot le 9
petit aboyeur pour 6 points
[Musique]
chacun
le chacal avec un cas
vous êtes en train de relayer la
propagande de Madame Aurore berger pour
faire croire que ceci est un acte de
violence est-ce que vous vous rendez
compte que tout le pays rigole là en
l'occurrence
c'est la propagande de votre député qui
est là ouais et alors il fait de la
propagande pourquoi à votre avis vous
allez voir vous êtes ridicule pour vous
en rendez même pas compte
l'oiseau
sa vie d'air pur est au fresh un oiseau
d'un peu de chasse et de pêche un oiseau
[Musique]
mais jamais rien ne l'empêche l'oiseau
d'aller plus haut et le gars que vous
voyez là c'est un cheminot de la SNCF
qui a été élu député alors ça ça reste
en travers de la gorge de toute la bonne
société que nous ayons fait élire des
travailleurs et vous venez maintenant
nous saouler avec une histoire de ballon
vous êtes grotesque grotesque ouais
carrément oui comment on fait pour
continuer cette émission si vous avez
déjà dit que j'étais ridicule grotesque
vous faites comme vous voulez si vous
voulez vous partez là l'image que donne
en particulier et les filles et
absolument effrayante pourquoi
je veux dire transformer l'Assemblée
nationale en camp de gitan et c'est pas
les Saintes-Maries-de-la-Mer je veux
dire il faut arrêter de donner ce
spectacle et de dégrader cette
république au point que maintenant tous
les jours sur les radios à la télé on
vous dit regardez il y a du monde dans
la rue donc il faut tout arrêter c'est
pas ça la démocratie on va se calmer
c'est une maladresse il faut pas dire ça
moi je suis dans une ville où il y a une
très forte communauté gitane enfin
honnêtement et s'il avait dit c'est le
souk le sou qu'on vous aurait dit ça
renvoie quoi le bazar on vous aurait dit
ça renvoie au commerce musulman enfin tu
arrêtes plus il aurait dû dire c'est le
bordel au moins personne n'aurait fait
vulgarité de vulgarité et de machisme
vous voyez ce que je veux dire Apolline
est-ce que vous savez que vous avez
touché les gens qui vous écoutent comme
Norman sauf que c'est leur cœur que vous
avez touché car j'ai eu énormément
j'ai eu énormément de messages de nos
auditeurs pour vous souhaiter votre fête
figurez-vous mais oui
ce matin comme cadeau on vous a prévu
une interview d'Éric Zemmour c'est
chouette
très sympa une interview pleine de
suspense même si je me suis laissé dire
qu'il allait parler d'immigration non le
grand remplacement plus de mosquées
arabouts un kebab il n'y a que des
étrangers islamisés à l'étranger la
civilisation islamique des robots des
étrangers les étrangers de femmes
voilées d'outils halal de kebab
coranique islamique musulman du Maghreb
et attendez en même temps la communauté
la communauté gitane que je connais pour
[__] bordel ils sont pas mauvais non
plus voilà mais on peut se dire les
choses et en même temps moi de samedi je
serai un combat de boxe j'aime la boxe
j'aime que les choses que les gens
n'aiment pas
tout le monde ces écolos de merde il
faut arrêter 2 minutes
ah oui carrément bon
matin encore un peu blanc un peu folle
encore il faut aller vous bronzer c'est
nature peinture c'est bien j'aime bien
me suis trompe pas la tête et je me
prends pas la tête non plus quoi
clairement la belle vie
sans souci
sans problème
lâchez-nous laissez-nous faire de la
politique arrêtez de venir sans arrêt
pour voir s'il y a pas moyen que deux
insoumis sans gueule entre eux le groupe
insoumis a pris une décision lui pas moi
je n'y étais pas ils ont pris cette
décision elle s'applique le mouvement
assoumis en quatre jours à la demande
d'Adrien cadenas a cessé d'être le
coordinateur qu'est-ce que vous voulez
de plus d'abord la notion de bonheur
elle est elle est très relative vous
savez c'est quand on se demande si on
est heureux qu'on ne l'est plus donc dès
qu'on se pose la question je réfléchis à
cette phrase
si on est heureux qu'on ne l'est plus
ok d'accord vous avez fait taire Daniel
cigogne n'est pas une mince affaire je
regrette de vous avoir fait confiance
vous êtes des gens sans principe 100
fois ni loi
restez là Monsieur Mélenchon faut pas
partir comme ça
bon voilà c'est la fin de cette émission